eight political parties are contesting
the vote on wednesday the frontrunners
are the governing people's movement for
the liberation of angola or mpla and its
long-standing rival and a former rebel
movement unita the national union for
the total independence of angola
stakes are high for the mpla in power
since angola gained independence from
portugal in 1975. it's led by incumbent
president joe lorenzo he was first
elected in 2017 and is seeking a second
term
critics say angola's oil wealth has
mainly benefited the former president
late jose eduardo de santos and his
family
many of the country's 33 million people
live in poverty and are seeking change
most of the people in angola don't work
and that destroyed the government's
reputation there's no political
intention to develop angola while others
view voting for the opposition as an
opportunity for change
[Music]
we're not content or happy with the
government's actions we hope for more
from them
for many the face of change is unique to
leader alberto costa jr who's
reinvigorated the opposition since
taking over in 2019
young people make up a third of the
population
and koster juniors appeal to them with
promises to reform the government and
tackle poverty and corruption
you need to build a strong front for
democratic change fundamentally because
there is a single party in power a
one-party regime
while the mpla remains the favorite
analysts and opinion polls predict a
tight race but the opposition and some
voters are questioning whether it will
be fair lorenzo's rebuffed the
opposition's criticism of the electoral
commission that's mostly led by members
of his party familia mala al jazeera